[Music]
my next guest is a comedian whose latest
album over easy is available now and who
can be seen at the just for laughs
comedy festival in montreal in late july
please welcome the very funny trevor
boris
hello
how are we
so i
i've been single so long my friends are
making me online date
and they put me on plenty of fish which
is of course based on line plenty of
fish in the sea
what they don't tell you is that these
fish have been thrown back
these
these are messed up fish no one wants
any more
although it's way better than the g
dating sites uh there's one called
manhunt
which that sounds romantic right
where'd you guys meet manhunt
it's crazy because like guys put naked
pictures of themselves on their profiles
which everybody can see which that to me
is creepy it's too far
you know call me old-fashioned
i just think the first time i see a
guy's penis you know should be in the
men's room with the club we just met at
i'm like a hopeless romantic i guess
my favorite though is grindr do you guys
know grinder
a few people it's
how you doing uh
if you don't know it's a it's a gay
dating app for your iphone and it's gps
based so it tells you how close other
gay people are to you
i know right
the first time i went on it my cousin
was on
he's not gay he's actually really
homophobic and just wants to make sure
there's no gaze close to him
it's like an early warning device for
him
warning gay approaching approaching
10 meters very left few left
but it's nice though because like i'm
from a small town where it's not really
cool to be gay uh like my town is so
small that like literally our pride
parade is like me opening the garage
door going happy bride and then slamming
it down
[Applause]
and then people would just chase me
small town like the only job i ever had
growing up was uh was at our airport in
lost and found
which really boring job a lot of lost
bags and that although there was this
one time and this is a true story this
guy came up to the counter in a
wheelchair and said that he had lost his
prosthetic legs
and i was like what and i started to
laugh
right but he was serious he was like
yeah i can't find my legs
and i was like how could you lose your
legs
again
he started getting all mad at me and i
was like all right well calm down
literally retrace your steps
because he was stumped he had no idea
you know he could have just kicked
himself he was
i've got 11 more if you want
so it's like i moved into
the gamerhood now
which is really nice and
i'm in probably the gayest building in
the world and you know as soon as you
get to my elevator there's a metal sign
in my elevator that says warning
excessive movement from jumping or
dancing will break the elevator
yes excessive dancing is an actual
problem in my building
like not just dancing dancing enough to
break an elevator
and enough times for someone to go okay
we need to put a sign in there
listen homos quit
we're breaking this down
but i guess the sign wasn't working
because now they put security cameras in
there thinking that's going to help and
uh well now the homos just think they're
going to be discovered
they're putting on shows in the elevator
the lion king just
in my opened
but it's nice i would like to meet
someone and get married because uh
that'd be great and it's so nice that
obama is finally behind us gays right
well
i'm from canada where we can get married
and it's interesting because like gay
couples from all over the world have
been coming to canada to get married
there because it's one of the only
countries where it's legal uh however if
you need to get a divorce one of the two
actually has to come back and live in
canada for a year first
which i don't think people realize so we
could easily see in a couple years like
hundreds of angry gay people from all
over the world
have to move to canada just to get a
divorce
i'd love to see that what brings you to
canada i hate him
all right you guys been a lot of fun
cheers thank you very much thank you
great
job come on fantastic thank you great
[Applause]